[Music]
growing up my dad gave my elder brother
and me any spare change he had so we
could buy the newest technology of that
time a desktop computer for when we went
to college every day he would come home
from work
put the rupee coins in her hands and we
would run into our rooms and put this
money in our piggy banks after a couple
of years we had decent amount of money
it was August of 2002 I was told we as
old then sitting in my room and working
on my homework when my dad stormed into
the room and it was upside like never
before even straight to the piggy bank
picked it up and smashed it to the
ground he then took the money and left
the room I was shocked
unsure of what just happened I went to
the ground to pick up the broken pieces
of piggy bank and look if there was any
money left there was none
it was when I realized our family was at
the bottom of the economic pyramid why
were we there
my dad had no stable job for years he
had no college degree either so when his
machine tools workshop ran out of
business
he went hustling to find a next job so
he could run the family with no history
of borrowing he was labeled risky and
costly and was turned away by local
banks leaving him no option but to take
a desperate measure it may sound cliche
but that broken piggy bank has become my
symbol of shattered dreams for my family
and many families around the world
trying to break the vicious cycles of
poverty as a teenager it was frustrating
to see newspapers claim the economy had
grown many fold while we were at the
very same place despite years of hard
work I wondered if a family was even
part of the economy our financial
struggles continued until I graduated
from college and found a job
at a bank yes a bank the system that
once rejected us has now become a
family's lifeline
isn't that an irony or is it what banks
and businesses are supposed to do
provide a lifeline to the community
around them I worked at this Bank and
provided a comfortable life to my family
but I couldn't erase the image of broken
piggy bank from my heart
I wondered how many families around this
world are taking desperate measures only
to see themselves stuck in a loop so in
2016 I decided to tackle this problem by
creating a technology product that would
provide microcredit to unbanked families
in India one of my first customers was
Sunil who wanted a loan for $500 to pay
for his college fee and continuous
education he had good grades from his
high school and earned a small income by
working part-time at a food delivery
company he and his family lived in a
shanty house in the city outskirts of
Bangalore his dad drove a taxi and
earned $200 a month when Sunil and his
dad went to the nearest bank to apply
for a loan they were rejected the reason
they were rejected was because of the
risky income profile of his family and
there was no profit to be made of a
small loan with our technology he could
apply for a loan from the comfort of his
mobile phone by taking photographs of
his documents and submitting an online
application it was approved instantly
honey could enroll in college the next
day where banks are unprofitable loan
our technology could see an opportunity
using mobile touch points we reduce the
cost structure and reinvented the
business model of a loan
however machine learning algorithms
could crunch through his bank accounts
and mobile data and saw an opportunity
and provided a small loan and the result
he paid back the loan in just nine
months we gave thousands of such loans
loans that helped tax
drivers small-business merchants
restaurant owners pay for that kids
school fee and advance the family
forward families that were traditional
ignored by the banks are now able to
access loans dream big and progress
ahead in life today Sunil is a proud
first-generation graduate of his family
he has a job as a car sales
representative and earn $600 a month he
has access to formal banks and health
care and doesn't have to take desperate
measures
to take care of his family the impact I
had on Sunil's life showed me that
technology can break traditional
business models and benefit billions of
people at the bottom of the pyramid
there is hope what was not possible many
years ago when my family suffered is
possible today thanks to mobile phones
and technology the upward mobility that
Sunil saw is a resounding example of how
removing barriers to financial access
can turn things around for people at the
bottom of the pyramid and there are more
than 4 billion people waiting at the
bottom of the pyramid making less than
$1,500 a year and looking to overcome
barriers in finance healthcare education
and employment and it's not a problem
specific to India or other developing
countries take your netid states for
example over the last 30 years the top
10% of the Americans saw their wealth
grew by 200% a staggering 200% but as
the bottom 50% remained at the same
place what do we all do about this from
here on I can see the world going in two
ways one companies and individuals don't
think about these 4 billion people they
think is the government's responsibility
to address this not this to this
resonates with me well as business
leaders we embrace reality we may not be
able to get rid of poverty completely
but we can do our best to remove the
systemic barriers in our society and
that's the path I choose to go down and
I
if you're an entrepreneur urge you to
create technology solutions that would
remove the economic asymmetry our world
is in it is difficult but not impossible
to create profitable businesses doing
this if you're an investor I urge you to
back bold ideas and commit to them over
long periods of time and not just look
for short-term opportunities in addition
to financial returns it's time investors
looked at economic inclusion created by
their investments when I moved to Bay
Area I was excited that I was dipping
into the technological feature a perfect
place I saw self-driving cars delivery
robots and drones but I also saw that
Valley was far from reality
a far from perfect place last year I
took an uber ride from San Francisco
Airport I started a conversation with
the driver and realized he was a college
dropout Stewart as we turned onto the
palm drive he got excited and asked me
what I was doing here I told him I was a
student his eyes lit up immediately and
said he too wanted to come to Stanford
and here he is working two jobs a day to
make ends meet if I don't have
conversations like those I fear I might
live in a bubble and be blind to people
living from paycheck to paycheck we all
live in a bubble if you don't see
janitors drivers and the lives of four
billion people breaking their piggy
banks every single day let's use
technology that can break barriers so
people don't have to break their piggy
banks
you
[Music]